직장인 여러분 ai로 ppt 만들어보신적 있으시죠.
그런데 솔직히 어떠셨나요.
올 깔끔하긴 한데 발표자료로 쓰긴 애매한데 회사 양식이랑 완전히
다른데 결국 내가 다시 다 고쳐야 안 해 아마 한 번쯤은 이런 생각
해보셨을 겁니다.
ai가 ppt를 못 만드는 걸까요
작년은 그럴 수 있었지만 26년 5월 지금은 절대 아닙니다.
문제는
ppt를 만드는 방식이 잘못됐기 때문입니다.
회사 양식을 반드시
지켜야 하는 경우 보안 때문에 외부 ai의 사용이 어려운 경우 발표용으로
화려한 구성이 필요한 경우 이미 만든 ppt를 수정해야 하는 경우 이 상황
들을 전부 같은 방식으로 해결하려고 하니까 어떤 경우는 의도대로
되는데 어떨 때는 안 되고 결과물이 만족스럽지 않았던 겁니다.
오늘 강의에서는 직장인이 실제 업무 에서 마주치는 ppt 제작
상황을 기준으로 어떤 ai 도구를 쓰고 어떻게 조합해야 바로 발표
절여로 쓸 수 있는 ppt를 만들 수 있는지 알려드리겠습니다.
핵심은 간단합니다.
내가 원하는 ppt 결과물에 맞게 ai 도구를 선택
하고 조합하는 것 여러 서비스를 다 구독해야 하냐고요.
그렇지 않습니다.
요즘 범용 lm의 ppt 제작 능력은 많이 평준화됐기 때문에 본인이 이미
쓰고 있는 채치 ppt 클로드 재미나이 같은 도구만으로도 충분히 업무
용 ppt를 만들 수 있습니다.
주력으로 쓰는 lm이 아니라면 무료로
도 충분합니다.
오늘은 크게 세 가지 상황을 다룹니다.
첫째 회사 양식을 엄격히 지켜야 하는 경우 둘째 자유로운 형식으로
퀄리티 높은 ppt를 만들어야 하는 경우 셋째 보완이 중요한 한경
에서 ai를 활용해야 하는 경우 공통적으로 자료조사가 중요한 경우는
범용 lm이나 노트북 lm의 심층 리서치 활용 방안 끝까지 보시면
ai ppt는 아직 실무에 쓰기 어렵다는 생각이 완전히 바뀌실 겁니다.
시작하기 전에 구독과 좋아요 부탁드립니다.